leona
audio est certainement là jeudi les
enfants vous
[Musique]
l'appliquez bonjour là bonjour les
enfants dis-moi léonard sam gagner les
enfants et moi parce que je suis
tellement de choses te demander si tu
pouvais pas nous raconter une fable de
la fontaine membre oui j'adore les
fables de la fontaine je les connais
presque tout par coeur alors quelle est
celle que tu veux nous raconter
le corbeau et le renard d'accord
maître corbeau sur un arbre perché
tenait dans son bec un fromage
maître renard par l'odeur alléché
8,1 à peu près ce langage et bonjour
monsieur du corbeau que vous êtes jolie
que vous me semblez beau sans mentir si
votre ramage se rapporte à votre plumage
vous êtes le phénix des hôtes de ces
bois ainsi mou le corbeau ne se sent
plus de joie et pour montrer sa belle
voix il ou un large bac
l'instant b53 le renard s'en saisit
colle ça me dit mon bon monsieur a
promis que tout flatteur vit au dépend
de celui qui l'écouté
cette leçon vaut bien un fromage sans
doute le corbeau honteux et confus
jura mais un peu tard qu'on ne l'y
prendrait plus mais voilà et bravo
léonard ses traits voir merci hein
c'était plaisir pour moi
aulas au secours casimir casimiro secoué
haïti mais j'ai vraiment pas le temps
les cabinets
tenez bon les enfants julie julie du
roquefort où je voulais que prend la clé
d'abord c'est convoiterait les enfants
soutenez moyens une gens de gens
[Musique]
bien merci merci les enfants mais
j'étais arrivé à temps que tu étais en
fâcheuse posture dit moi je suis monté
là haut pour pour occire essais des
croupiers j'ai perdu l'habitude des
tubes voilà là oui tu as appelé casimir
je les ai vus passer sous peu s'il est
d'appeler j'ai critiqué au secours
des idées venues il est arrivé
tranquillement et avec un grand sourire
et m'a dit excuse-moi françois mais je
suis très près c'est vraiment difficile
à comprendre parfois s'est passé à
l'attention de nos relations et casimir
qu'est ce que tu fabriques excusez moi
mais j'ai vraiment propre travail
ce quasi mais il ya des moments où il
est né mais tu sais il ne faut pas lui
en vouloir c'est un passionné et ça
c'est bien mais quand même il pourrait
nous dire tu à faire avec sa brouette
attention il revient nous allons essayer
de lui barrer le passage
attention demande dépasse pas au
passeport à julien seron 15 me vous
voyez bien que j'ai du travail à la dino
d'abord ce que tu es en train de faire
écouter plus tard j'enregistre le
passerez les 100 je vous raconterai la
liste des habitants vas-y vas-y l'usiné
la liste des habitants ce qui veut dire
écoute nous serons toujours ça à temps
allons travailler sur les origines est
[Applaudissements]
en toi enfin ça y est j'ai la liste a
tué déjà voté quasi minoui bien vite
j'ai besoin de toi beaucoup de casimir
tout à l'heure tu t'es prêt à mener
c'est tombé du haut de la cage à poules
maintenant tu veux que je vienne à toute
vitesse nouveaux vieux voudrais savoir
ce que tu veux mais je sens tout à
l'heure je n'avais pas besoin de toi et
maintenant c'est le contraire
que voulez vous répondre allez allez dd
décembre pour qu'ils m'aident bon
d'accord je descends quasi niamey a
toujours dû me faire tomber encore voilà
bon voila il faudrait également que peu
appelle tous les enfants bon bah écoute
ils sont fait ce que tout ça voulait
faire un jeu les enfants oui eh bien on
va le faire le jeu là bas là bas sur le
talus
voilà
comme ça
dis-moi léonard tu n'as pas envie de
changer d'air toi commence à changer ni
ben allez voir ailleurs voyage voyage
n'est rien cinquante chiens pourquoi ça
coûte cher les voyages pas s'il faut
utiliser un moyen de transport le bâton
l'avion le train pour se transporter
exactement mais il n'est pas possible de
de faire un voyage sans utiliser un
moyen de transport si si un pied mais un
an là c'est un tout petit voyage
c'est une randonnée une promenade
remarque il ya aussi la possibilité de
faire un pèlerinage en pèlerinage c'est
un voyage conflit pour des motifs
religieux le pèlerinage des chrétiens
arabes et musulmans à la mecque bout des
hindous banc du gang et de ces gens se
rendre dans ces endroits un pied à pied
mais appuyé c'est très fatigant mais
alors si j'ai bien compris il faut
d'abord que je fasse des économies si je
veux voir du pays exact ou alors tu as
le rêve le rêve le rhin c'est un truc
qui te permet d'amener les chutes du
niagara et d'un pack de saint
pétersbourg aux indes au japon en une
nuit sans quitter ton lit mon lit mais
on doit rolly en voyage quoi tu tues
dans oui mais mais qui t'empêche de
rêver que tu voyages voilà tu fermes les
yeux en route jeudi je vais partir pour
honolulu au nul le voyage commence
tu fais ta valise
tu descends dans la rue tu es à
l'aérodrome oui tu montes dans l'avion
où je suis déjà dans les noix
aux jeunes n'est pas la mer et prom
non mais c'est le pacifique où il
croyait au dos lui il te voilà déjà en
train de danser sous le soleil un moyen
de queen
puis dans
fuyant
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
tu es dedans
thüga
[Musique]
maintenant je dors pas au léonard jeu
mauvais choix dans un mois le nez
pourquoi dans un - mais je pars à
honolulu ça me plait mois cet endroit
aux voisins comme on commence à en
allant me coucher tiens pardi mais quand
leonard au revoir
il ya quelques jours j'ai été rendre
visite à mon cousin américain il habite
en normandie est alors dans son jardin
il ya un une mare une main vous savez ce
que c'est qu'une mare et oui alors moi
j'ai vu que dans cette mare il y avait
des tas d'animaux très jolie et très
intéressant et je voudrais bien les
mettre dans ma marc à moi alors
malheureusement j'ai oublié leur nom
alors j'ai été voir mon ami leonard nous
avons fait ensemble une liste d'animaux
mais attend de les mettre dans ma part
j'aimerais être sûrs qu'ils s'y plaisent
alors je voudrais que vous m'aidiez la
volonté d casimir les stars on va
l'aider alors casimir août et couteaux
qui nous lie la liste des animaux
d'abord je voudrais mettre dans ma mère
des grenouilles à c'est possible mais
évidemment évidemment casimir du comet
des grenouilles dans tamar et
grenouilles se sont ce sont des
batraciens bien suite je voudrais mettre
également d'être à rabat
pourquoi
est ce que tu dis que les avions dans
les basses dans la mêlée rocher bon
des crustacés bien décrire est aussi
j'aimerais bien mettre
les crevettes également vive dans la
vous savez comment les attrape qu'on les
pêche
en poussant un filet c'est ça bon on
s'enligne pour les convaincus et des 40
chats étanche oui oiseaux l'attend je
peux vivre dans la mare de casimir c'est
bien car sans lui kazemi vente un
poisson d'accord des macros et macro
de la crau vives ou
les maquereaux vivent dans la mer c'est
quand ils sont tout petits les
maquereaux on les met dans les boîtes de
conserve comme les sardines enfin ça
c'est très bon et très excellent bien et
des langoustes et ce que son métier
langoustes
c'est dommage landes ou sur les taux
également dans la mer n'est ce pas c'est
comment les attraper longueur
d'ondés pas nier c'est également un
crustacé est alors également que des
biens et des carpes est-ce que je peux m
d'écart
week-end finir tour avec une carte dans
sa marque c'est vrai france soir we came
et 1 et 2 et qui on a très bien des
tritons j'aime bien les tris compris
tance oui oui des sachets
non c'est un batracien voilà un
batracien tous les batraciens ont les
pattes palmées à et des poules pas
est-ce que je peux mettre des
programmeurs tout comme les musées
pieuvre sandrine non plus que subit le
tueur
c'est comment une poulpe
ça ça des longs bras avec des ventes
nous et ça serait surtout de crabes
crevettes et de coquillages a des
tentacules et la dépendance actuelle
voilà et des crapauds ce que je m'étais
crabe commun ici c'est également un
batracien enfin je m'en doutais oui des
gardons mais gardons des gardes aux
dépouilles qui garde au nom oui si c'est
cassé qu'est ce que c'est un gardon
c'est un petit poisson alors je peux le
montant avoisine et l'accord et
débranchaient des brochets
ils voulaient me brancher sera heureux
s'il est dense dans un lac dans un grand
espace d'eau il lui faut de l'eau claire
et de la place alors exactement vie pour
les brochets moi que je vous remercie
pour être sûr de pas me tromper une
dernière fois je récapitule je peux donc
mettre dans ma mère des grenouilles des
tanches 1 des quarts des tritons des
crapauds et des gardons un c'est bien ça
oui casimir ils sont très heureux je
vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans mon pays
les hirondelles pour tous les jours des
bretelles un de mes amis est pas moins
au piano tous tu
connais aussi des catalans otago totaux
soit droit qui font du travail au fond
nous ici je suis sans grand entrain bo
est en excellent contreur janvier
m
ici
je suis un grand inventeur
aussi et
prestidigitateur et jours suivants
après chaque les cannetanes guettant
d'escargots tôt la trompette
joris bleus sur les premiers des six
trous sur les prototypes dans le pays
vous pouvez voir un éléphant qui tous
les soirs rachou
sur les trottoirs croyez moi ou pas les
six mois que je suis en grand
salut en compte
chagny
[Musique]
je suis encore un monstre
aussi les retours
prestidigitateur
les rues sont couvertes de flopper les
enfants jamais d'autres heureux ya du
soleil même en hiver on n'a jamais mabri
de guérison sankara mais très rigoureux
du bien
l'amitié sera éternelle c'est la
dernière de nouvelles je suis en
grandeur
et on excelle en contres chergui
je suis très
je suis un bon temps
ici et rêver
esprit
m
il
en clair
et un
stylet 3
en fait
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'est pas là
nous il a été chercher des ballons
heureusement pour lui que tu dis
françois et tous les enfants se sont
moqués de moi ils m'ont indiqué toute
une liste d'animaux qui devait venir
dans la mare ils ont tous refusé
heureusement j'ai trouvé une famille de
crevettes et quelques amis trappe qui
ont bien voulu venir des crevettes et
crabes mais où là tu fais ta main dans
un endroit très joli tout au bout de la
plage au milieu des rochers
c'est une mare d'eau de marc casimir et
tu voulais y mater grenouille ouais et
alors
[Musique]